promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ProMix cité l'émission
qui vous parle de la place des femmes
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui
focus sur l'index de l'égalité
professionnelle 5 ans après son
instauration ellisabeth B souhaite le
réformer pour ditel le rendre plus
ambitieux transparent et fiable
rappelons qu'il ne concerne que les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés qui
s'auto-évalue via plusieurs indicateurs
comme les écarts de salaires ou encore
les augmentations celles qui obtiennent
moins de 75 points doivent prendre des
mesures coercitives sous peine de
sanction financière et parmi les pistes
envisagées le gouvernement souhaite
justement revoir ce fameux seuil de 50
salariés rendre plus transparent
l'indicateur sur les écarts de
rémunération et renforcer les sanctions
financières à noté qu'éliisabeth BN
souhaite également lancer une
concertation sur le congé parental avec
deux objectifs améliorer sa rémunération
mais surtout réduire les interruptions
de carrière des femmes et ainsi
encourager une répartition plus
équitable avec les hommes voilà promic
cité c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite sur Public
Sénat promixité vous a été présenté par
ngj acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle